that was the reason why there had been
rumblings that it could be something
that was shelved many within the
conservative party don't like this
national insurance rise that will now
take place from april 1.25 percentage
points for workers but also 1.25
percentage points up
for employers
as well it broke a manifesto commitment
from 2019 so there had been speculation
it could have been something boris
johnson suspended or delayed in order to
get a few of his
backbenchers on side if he had done i
think he would have uh ended up in a
fight with the man that he stood next to
there the chancellor rishi sunak
and ultimately i think that could have
been one of the reasons why this has not
happened a joint piece penned in the
sunday times by both men this morning so
clearly wanting to show a unified front
in which they say we must clear the
covered backlogs with our plan for
health and social care and now is the
time to stick to that plan we must go
ahead with the health and care levy it
is the right plan and they go on though
to sort of throw a bit of red meat and
reassurance to back benches by saying we
are tax cutting conservatives we are
thatcherites in the sense that we
believe in sound money there is no magic
money tree i think though what many
conservative mps are asking themselves
is whether you can be a tax cutting
thatcherite conservative while at the
same time whacking up taxes uh to the
highest level that they've been
in a very long time i think this move
does show that boris johnson maybe feels
he's got uh a bit more political
strength and authority than he maybe did
even a week ago that he could do
something that would be uh unpopular
with his backbenchers we spoke to one of
them robert halfon who chairs the
education select committee who was
urging a rethink
if i have a choice between taxing
low-income workers so if you're a worker
on twenty thousand pounds you're gonna
be paying an extra 90 pounds if you're a
worker on 30 000 pounds you have to pay
an extra 214 pounds with this tax that's
a huge amount of money especially with
costs in energy going up in petrol and
diesel and food and and everything else
so a much better option in my view would
be a win for tax on
big business
i think what this decision does do
though is pile the pressure on to the
government to do something in another
policy area to help cost of living we
know that in a little over a week
there'll be an announcement about where
the energy price cap is going to with
expectations of bills for people on
standard tariffs going up by about 50
come april so that is one thing i think
we
could expect from the government in the
next week in really what is going to be
a very very busy week we are expecting
announcements to celebrate the celebrate
for the government anyway the second
anniversary of brexit tomorrow as i say
a lot of movement around ukraine the
leveling up white paper that key plank
of government policy coming midweek as
well and all of that as we still wait
for that report from sue gray into
alleged
number 10 parties which could come any
day now
all of that
is clearly very serious big issues to
deal with but i think it's politically
convenient to say the least that
in a week where boris johnson's own
track record and his
honesty and credibility will once again
once again come under
the spotlight that there are plenty of
other big things that he can point to
and plenty of other issues
that are sucking up some of the
bandwidth as well